c'est la panique et les froid
après le séisme qui a réduit ses maisons
en décombres
ces résidents transportent un corps
inanimé
les morts se comptent par centaines la
majorité sont des enfants
la maison s'est écroulée nous a
ensevelir raconte cette résidente j'ai
déterré deux de mes enfants j'en ai 7
Hélène iI est toujours porté disparu
[Musique]
raconte qu'il a eu à peine le temps de
se sauver avant que tous ces fondre les
secours s'organisent tant bien que mal
les rues se transforment en salle des
urgences devant l'ampleur de la
catastrophe le chef de l'administration
de la ville s'effondre en larmes
les villages sont détruits et nous avons
besoin d'équipements lourds beaucoup de
route sont coupées
[Musique]
à la tombée de la nuit ce médecin suture
une plaie éclairée par un téléphone
cellulaire les survivants s'abritent car
le risque d'une réplique n'est pas
écarté
plus de dommages l'onde a provoqué des
glissements de terrain rendant
impossible évacuation de villages
entiers et faisant redouter un bilan
encore plus lourd ici Yasmine Khayat
Radio-Canada MONT